Oliver Anthony
Oliver Anthony is the singer behind the
song about the rich men from Richmond
and I I perused his YouTube channel
because that song is good he's obviously
a real talent it's not you know it's I
it's not the greatest song I've ever
written but he's a real talent I love
that the song went viral he seems great
and I was perusing his other songs his
other songs are better than the one that
went viral
he's a he's just a real musical town
he's got this great voice kind of like
Levon Helm he's a terrific little dobro
guitar player and his other songs
frankly are even more musically
interesting and more my style at least
my style is probably not indicative of
popular music tastes so maybe that's why
the other one went viral but maybe the
best thing that guy has done is he was
just opening up a show his first show I
guess since all of this went down and he
opened it up by reading the Bible
before we start singing and I mean we
because I hope y'all are going to be
singing too
[Applause]
I just had something I felt compelled to
share with you
this is in psalm
psalm 37. 12-20
the wicked plot against the righteous
and gnashed their teeth at them but the
Lord laughs at the wicked for he knows
their day is coming
it goes on and on he reads this long
Bible passage
and I thought this is great and by the
end people applaud
very shat woohoo and then he starts
singing a song this is really great
stuff
because
it shows that this guy's purpose is not
just to make money
this guy's purpose is not just to become
famous this guy's purpose is not just to
get his one song out there
this guy is doing all those things
I can't even imagine how much money this
guy's made in one weekend when he went
that Viral got the number one song in
America he obviously got very famous a
lot of people have heard his music
he would seem from just that one little
clip he would seem to be doing it not
just for his own self-aggrandizement but
for the glory of God which is really
what it's all about I just love that I
just love that I've been going back
through Aristotle's Nick and Mickey and
ethics narasaddle points out all these
different kinds of Virtues and he says
you know wealth is not a virtue
it's nice to have material stuff well
you need it for a happy life you need
some material stuff but it's not it's
not a virtue because it's not for itself
it's an instrument wealth is just there
to get you something else
this is true of so much your
professional success what's it for
so that you can hang a trophy on your
wall at the end of the day so that you
can get employee of the month
what's it for
Fame what's it for what do you so that
people can be nice to you when you walk
down the street
and so people can ask you for pictures
what's it for is it
to bring glory to God and to bring
people closer to him that's ultimately
what it ought to be for right
and that appears to be what he's doing
seems to have his priorities in order
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles you
know a company is looking out for you
when they upgrade your service without
even charging you for it it's great news
for new and current Pure Talk customers
pure talk just added data to every plan
and includes a mobile hotspot with no
price increase whatsoever if you've
considered pure talk before but have not
made the switch take a look again for
just 20 bucks a month you will get
unlimited talk text and now 50 more 5G
data plus their new mobile hotspot this
is why I love pure talk it's veteran
owned they only hire the best customer
service team located right here in the
great us of a most families are saving
almost a thousand dollars a year while
enjoying the most Dependable 5G Network
in America remember
you vote with how you spend your money
so stop supporting woke wireless
companies that don't support you when
you go to puretalk.com Knowles Canada
wlas you'll save an additional fifty
five zero percent off your first month
because they value you
that's puretalk.com
Wireless for Americans by Americans This
is a feel-good story
the jury jury in Texas just awarded a
woman
1.2 billion dollars after her boyfriend
engaged in revenge porn
now before you say that seems a little
steep 1.2 billion that's a listen there
are a lot of people who don't even have
1.1 billion dollars you know much less
1.2 before you say it's a little steep
this guy wasn't engaging in
run-of-the-mill revenge porn I think all
revenge porn is pretty egregious and
should be punished pretty severely but
this guy was obviously a complete
lunatic uh the the ex-girlfriend filed a
lawsuit
which alleged and I guess the court is
ruled in her favor that this guy created
a website
and a publicly accessible Dropbox folder
and fake social media profiles to
disseminate
porn of this woman
how did he get the porn you might say
well that woman shouldn't have sent him
naughty pictures that's not exactly what
happened the guy
obtained the porn
by accessing security cameras in the
woman's home
and taking pictures and video of her
when she was unaware that's according to
the Washington Post
then he he emailed her and said you will
spend the rest of your life trying and
failing to wipe yourself off the
internet Happy Hunting
he continued to just harass this woman
and try to ruin her life he's obviously
really really sick really perverted guy
and a psycho in all sorts of other ways
and anyway after this long and drawn out
breakup he he decided to uh
just try to ruin her life so the jury
Awards her 1.2 billion dollars I think
this is great
it's fine you know this is really psycho
behavior and people who engage in it
should should have the steepest
punishments the other reason this is
really good just from a political
perspective is
in this decision this court is
acknowledging the value of Honor which
is something that democracies in general
don't always place a high enough value
upon and degraded democracies that that
degrade into mob rule or oligarchy or
something like that they really don't
place value on honor
one of the pitfalls of democracy is that
it it can become too materialistic and
it can be become too full of envy and
resentment to focused on just stuff and
coveting other people's stuff
and what this decision says is
look what happened here is a guy spread
some pictures of his ex-girlfriend
around
it's not like he went and stole her
her car he didn't steal her laptop he
didn't steal her jewelry he stole her
honor he stole her reputation and what
the jury is saying is had he stolen her
car they might say okay he owes you 20
grand stole some jewelry okay he owes
you five grand stole some but he stole
your honor well he owes you 1.2 billion
dollars
that's good we must
restore a sense in this country of the
importance of honor and the importance
of modesty why is it a big deal that he
got some naked pictures of her what the
Liberals will say is well because she
didn't consent to it
sure that's that's part of it
but consent is not the only moral
Criterion of course it's not the most
important one not by a long shot
if it were merely a violation of consent
that would be serious would it be 1.2
billion dollars serious
no I don't think had he just taken a
picture of her sitting on a beach
well that's a bad example because she'd
be wearing a bikini if he took a picture
of her sitting in a burqa imposed of it
they might say well that's creepy and
weird but we're gonna award you I don't
know 100 bucks 200 bucks 300 bucks no
one would be would be awarding this
woman 1.2 billion dollars they're
rewarding her that money because
they're acknowledging that modesty is a
virtue it's valuable people cherish it
and when that is taken away from
somebody that is a more egregious
offense and a mere violation of consent
it's a really good decision I'm not sure
that this was all conscious in the minds
of the of the judge or the jar were
there jurors here I'm not even sure but
but that is the effect of the decision
and it's
it's something that you see this in the
the Trad wife movement you see this in
the movement away from feminism and some
aspects of the sexual revolution in a
way you kind of see it with the metoo
movement which fizzled Hollywood made
sure to stamp that one out real quick
destroy their whole business model
threaten their whole business model but
you you saw those inklings there a
turning away from this shallow language
Liberal Liberal libertarian kind of
language that whereby consent is the
only important
moral category no
no there's there are more important
things honor is important too boy what a
great clip that was now make sure that
you ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles show
we'll see you next time